My solution, I admit, is not the most elegant,
but it's the simplest that I could find
without going into more complicated data structures.
The key thing is that I'm going to go through all my data items,
there's a for loop over here.
As I explained before, this gets me the length of the data sequence;
this gives me a list of all the indices from zero to six, in this case.
We're going to go through these indices one after another in this variable "i."
Now comes the tricky part. I pick the i'th data item,
and I count how often does this occur in the entire list.
For the first data item, 1--
the argument here would be 1--
and the count will give me 1
because there's exactly 1 occurrence of 1.
But for the third item--
as we know, "i" will be 2 now, going from zero on--
then this thing over here will give me the number 5.
I'm going to hit count.
I get back 3 because there's 3 occurrences of 5.
Now I need to find the maximum count,
and specifically the data item that maximizes the count.
For that, I've implemented a variable called "modecnt" that I've set to zero.
If my current count exceeds modecnt, then I've found a new winner.
So as a new winner, I'm going to set the new data item
to the winner--the mode--
and I update modecnt
to reflect the fact that this new winner has a higher count in the data set
than my initial zero.
I iterate this. Out comes the mode.
When I run it for this data set, I get 5.
If you got this right, then you know a lot about programming.
This was really a nontrivial programming quiz.